stop this okay there he is hey justin
all right you got your feet i see joey
doing push-ups right now how delayed is
the stream yeah yeah he's warming up
he's warming up all right
[Music]
i don't know if you can hear us i can
hear you i can see you i'm watching this
and i'm just thinking i'm not worthy
this is way too beautiful
okay okay so you guys are you guys are
gonna comment i'm gonna hang up and
we're gonna do this
yeah absolutely i mean we the sound was
better before what happened should we
show it
full screen like without the layout
should i keep justin on the call
before it was louder i think we should
have just um
it might have been because we were
closer to the camera okay i'll keep you
on the call just
talk talk us through the call yeah yeah
talk us through it
are we good are we waiting you're ready
wait hold on should we have it
completely
correct no it's great okay you can see
it all
you ready all right tell joey tell joey
thank you we're about
yeah thank you for the hurricane uh
victims thank you joe sells for your
for taking it to the face thank you
thanking you joey salas here we go
here we go all right [ __ ] here we go
okay so you can see this [ __ ] right yeah
oh we see it here we go i'm doing it
three ah this is so good two
one oh
[ __ ] crazy
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
holy [ __ ] open your eyes when you spray
the saline
we got a slo-mo version of this just
telling him what to do
[Laughter]
ready
[Music]
[Laughter]
this is why cops use this to to deter
people and also why
potential victims of sexual assault you
use this method of uh you know uh
uh we didn't bring any water
we don't want to walk you back in here
with that milk can we get a can we get a
word from him
can you get a one a word from joey oh
yeah joey here they want to hear from
you go home
why are you drunk does the milk even
work does it do anything or is that just
like an urban legend
joey how are you feeling are you okay
this is a stupid idea
that's the that's that's joey
he's blind right now
he got hit pretty hard
to be donating right now we're doing
this for you to give us
money come on open your
[ __ ] peepers let's [ __ ] watch the
show open the papers let you live
let justin help you joey
there's people walking by in the
background oh my god
there's people walking
this is hard to watch he's running out
of milk i love it like
like how much research did you do in
regards to it
[Music]
he said i said how much research did you
do
in regards to you know overcoming this
and he said
i asked him specifically because i was
like you've done have you done this
before because i don't want you to get
too [ __ ]
he said i've done it twice before i
asked him to but he told me
before it was watered down and this time
it's not oh my god
it was watered down before wait this
milk
september milk expires september 20th
he's good he's good
okay that's fresh milk that's fresh i
got my dates mixed up i got
i got my as much as i'd love for that to
be rotten milk it's fresh
is he all right it's interesting how he
just dumps it on his face
just desperate
you know it wasn't me it would have been
someone else so you know at least i had
that to sort of
you're here i got some saline for your
eyeballs ready come on look up look up
yeah now you're at least able to open
your [ __ ] eyeball all the way like
all the way
there you go there you go like a little
stream right here
you all better be donating
is a fraction of the pain that
the people in houston and
you know justin put it in perspective
put in perspective we shouldn't feel too
bad
is he feeling any better it looks like
he just went into a bit of a rage
oh here you want some more yeah it's
starting to get a little better i think
it's getting better we're talking a
little bit better yeah
let's hear from him i mean you know
yeah he's gonna need a couple shots
after this i think
can we get a word from joey let me get
an update on yeah
you're not okay we're getting close to
75k buddy
send your second intern with some water
you need water he wants water yeah
uh we don't actually have an extra
person
a lot of fountain
keep donating this is all for charity
guys
yo everybody oh boy
i was just thanking you for all you've
done for the people in houston i mean
this is a really symbolic moment you've
got more donations than the
the jake paulers in a single day well
not the strongest army are they
guys you better be donating right now i
mean come on we're at 73 three thousand
we gotta hit 75 for joey he just took it
this man's in a lot of pain and you know
to make it worthwhile we need your
donations
his whole face turned brown when that
[ __ ] hit it i'm gonna believe it i was
like
are you looking for water to drink or to
what rinse your face i need a drink
he needs a drink we're going to come
back he can see again you can see he can
see
that's good congratulations i love you i
love you buddy
we've got water on the way we have
someone getting water for you okay joey
all right all right okay i'm gonna hang
out
we did it all right so dry off and we'll
see you soon joey
all right all right talk to you guys yep
wow that was special that was beautiful
holy crap hey donations are back up
right now you guys don't see them
trickling
we want to get up to 75k because that's
what this is for we want to see if we
can get to that number
that was kind of exceeded my
expectations for what this stream could
become
joey salads got pepper sprayed by justin
rohrland
yeah right you're telling me sprayed him
in the [ __ ] face you're telling me
we're only at 73
at 73. well how are we not at 200 000
right now
because the webpage crashed we should be
a lot higher for
about an hour this man made a sacrifice
jesus well we're going to get him back
in here we're going to talk to him as he
was
as he was screaming and crying did he
say i love you ethan he did something
you did say that
is that some kind of like deep masochism
that was kind of a moment of purity and
trueness right
i love joey too it's a it's a very it's
complicated kind of like it's
complicated
facebook at a label it'd be it's
complicated oh good
this is a man in pain right now watching
the spit dribble down
really like viscous i kind of feel like
i'm in like the roman colosseum like
watching someone get eaten by a lion
like here we are like
eating grapes with julius caesar dan
just delivered the water oh
he's gonna drink it don't spit it out he
spit it right out
i think he's trying not to vomit i think
he's just trying to distract himself
from the pain
going up we're going up thank you thank
you for all your donors
thank you guys this is huge yeah we got
to upload this joey sells clip by itself
with the donation
he's such a champ let me give you the
back story on this joey cell tell me
because i'm kind of a novice to this
well the whole joey stewart's joey
salads backstory is a whole journey but
i announced this charity stream about a
week ago and joey texted me and he's
like
yo i want to come pepper spray myself
for the charity stream so it was his
idea
and i was like dude i love it i love it
[Music]
what do you say i don't know i think
he's having a bit of a
rage meltdown right now
he looks pretty fun yeah wow let's give
this man a shot
are his eyes like swollen yes probably
we're gonna get a close-up look at those
eyes
once we get the milk off his body
because you don't want it to smell like
pepper spray and milk in here
that's my dream man that's what belly
button smells like
pepper spray milk
i think he's like tripping on acid right
now
he's trying to describe his experience
but he can't even come up short
come on guys we're at 74 000 give joey
let's get up to 75. this guy the least
you could do
because the whole point was to get to 75
for what this guy just did we did it
before
before the donations because we did it
in good faith yeah we knew we'd make it
to 75 we knew it would be worth it we're
getting close
um i have a couple more videos on deck
if you guys are wondering what's coming
up next we're just
past 74. just by the way thank you guys
joey's walked out of frame
what a god wow